okay
well welcome everybody and thank you so
much for coming to today's event
on climate policy and politics which is
sponsored by the policy lab
and the institution for social and
policy studies
i'm john dearborn and i'm a postdoc in
the policy lab and the center for the
study of representative institutions
and i'm going to help moderate today's
event before i introduce
our speaker today i'd like to begin by
thanking lemore peer
and pam green for all of their hard work
in helping to coordinate and set up this
virtual event
as well as all of our events this
semester in the isps policy related
skills training series
i'd also like to thank isps director
alan gerber for his support of our
virtual programming
and i'd like to encourage all of our
students in the audience to check out
our schedule of isps policy related
skills training events over the next
couple of weeks
it's a pleasure today to introduce our
guest speaker professor leah stokes
a political scientist who is leading the
field in studying energy
climate and environmental politics leah
is assistant professor of political
science
and an affiliate with the brenn school
of environmental science and management
and the environmental studies department
at the university of california santa
barbara
within american politics her work
focuses on representation and public
opinion
voting behavior and public policy
particularly at the state level
and within environmental politics her
research examines
climate change renewable energy water
and chemicals policy
leah's book short circuiting policy seen
here
published in 2020 by oxford university
press
examines the role that utilities have
played in promoting climate denial
and rolling back clean energy laws it
received the 2020 best energy book award
from the american energy society
and was listed in the new york times
five climate books from 2020.
i also have to point out as a scholar of
american political development myself
that this phenomenal book is part of
oxford's studies in post-war american
political development series
and what an amazing work of apd
scholarship this is
leah has also contributed to the
anthology all we can save
which is a collection of essays written
by influential women in the climate
space
her academic research has been published
in some of the top journals in our field
such as the american political science
review and the american journal of
political science
and she has also published articles in
such outlets as the new york times and
the washington post
to our audience as i said i will be
moderating the q a portion of today's
talk
i would invite you to submit questions
if they occur to you during the talk
itself
via the chat function and once we go to
the formal q a
i will call on folks using the raise
hand function
i would also note that this event is
being recorded
during the talk itself i ask that you
please mute yourselves
and turn off your videos and leah thank
you so much for joining us today
well thanks so much for having me i've
spent a little bit of time at yale it's
a great community and i know
a little bit about isps and it's really
a wonderful place to be studying palsy
so i'm thrilled
to have the chance to um share with you
today
so i'm just going to share my slides
full screen
okay great so today i'm going to talk
about my book which john did a very
generous job
introducing it's called short circuit
short circuiting policy
and i'm also going to talk about some of
the policy work that i have been doing
with some of the recent reports i have
released on clean energy which um inform
a lot some of the conversations that
we're having right now about how to
decarbonize our electricity system
so the challenge that we face is
very large we have to clean up our
electricity system
quickly in order to decarbonize our
economy i often say
that cleaning up the electricity system
is the first linchpin in economy-wide
decarbonization
why is that well if we do clean up our
electricity system
it allows us to electrify large parts of
transportation through things like
electric vehicles
buildings through things like heat pumps
and induction stoves
and also parts of heavy industry and
when we add up all these sectors we
could get to emissions reductions of
between
70 to 80 percent through clean
electricity
and electrification so before the last
couple years we were talking about
2050 as the timeline for clean
electricity and that was because we were
talking about economy-wide
decarbonization
on those timelines and you can see here
that if we set a benchmark from the year
2000 and we draw a straight line out to
2050
then essentially each year clean power
has to grow by two percentage points
annually
and although this ends in 2018 the data
from 2020 is actually 40
so we're directly on track now but what
you should notice is that we've been
really living on borrowed
time with our nuclear and hydropower
fleet which have been
largely flat and in the case of the
nuclear fleet have a large potential to
be declining
and so we actually need renewables to be
growing much faster in order to keep
pace with this timeline
now this isn't the timeline we're
talking about anymore
we're talking about decarbonizing the
grid by 2035 this is what president
biden campaigned and went on and it's
very active area of discussion in policy
right now
so under that scenario we actually need
to be growing clean electricity by about
four percentage points every year
and that doesn't even take into account
uh the growing
load um that will be necessary to deal
with electrification so
that four percentage points could be
masking you know massive growth in the
overall electricity system meaning that
if we don't just need really 100
clean power we need like 200 percent
clean power and so that could be rather
than four percentage points on a 100
basis it could be like eight percentage
points on a 200 percent basis so it's a
lot to be doing very quickly
if you're interested in these arguments
and trying to kind of get a sense of
what i'm talking about here
i actually made a video which summarizes
this argument from my book
it's called the narwhal curve and we
released it with grist
and it's quite a nice little
three-minute video which kind of gives
you the basics of these ideas
and can be used in classes or shared
with other people who maybe don't know a
lot about the electricity system
[Music]
now my book looks at the state level and
that is because
the federal government has really failed
in terms of
amplifying clean electricity throughout
the 1990s advocates tried to pass and
failed to pass renewable portfolio
standards which are the main policy uh
i'll be talking about today
sometimes called clean electricity
standards they're very similar
uh what it is it is a policy that says
by a certain year like 2035 we have to
have a certain
percentage of our electricity system
from either clean or renewable sources
like 100
clean electricity by 2035. so these
renewable portfolio standards were
developed in the 1990s
and advocates were trying to get one
passed through congress but they failed
and i tell the history of those efforts
in the book now the closest we have come
was just over a decade ago in the waxman
marquee bill which you may know is the
very large
climate bill that passed the house but
did not pass the senate and that policy
included a federal renewable portfolio
standard for 20
renewable power by 2020 and it actually
had a provision that allowed eight
percent of that to be met with energy
efficiency
so that policy when i looked back on it
for my book
it wasn't considered ambitious at the
time but what's so interesting is that
when we look back on it had we passed
that policy we actually would have been
further along than we are today now of
course the biden harris campaign
uh was really focused on 100 clean
electricity by 2035 and this is
something that the administration
has also signaled that is planning on
working towards this year
so in the absence of federal action on
clean power states have really been
leading the way
and throughout the 90s and early 2000s a
majority of states passed renewable
portfolio standards and then later on
expanded them to higher percentages and
expanded them to include clean power
which usually
includes nuclear at the carbon free
resource potentially carbon capture and
sequestration although that largely does
not exist
and sort of other eligible resources
outside of just renewables
in addition states passed a policy
called net metering sometimes called net
energy metering
this is a policy that allows you to put
solar on your roof
and feed the extra kilowatt hours you
make
from that resource onto the grid and to
be paid for that
supply and what rate do you get paid at
well you get paid the same
uh amount that you would be buying
electricity so if you buy electricity
for let's say
15 cents a kilowatt hour you would also
be paid
15 cents a kilowatt hour and that's why
it's net right it's the difference
between the amount of kilowatt hours you
bought in a month versus the amount you
put onto the grid
and that would be your bill and as you
can see here again the vast majority of
states i believe the number is 42 past
these policies throughout the 90s and
early 2000s
now this effort has only amplified in
the last few years and we are now in a
situation where more than one in three
americans
live in a place today targeting 100
clean power
whether that's the states that i'm
showing here or
many cities across the country as well
so you can see here that
many states have passed policies
targeting 100 percent clean power
with the exception of washington and
colorado none of them are really as
ambitious as the federal policy
colorado has a plan for 80 clean power
by 2030
which is directly on the pathway to 100
clean by 2035
and washington state with this large
hydropower resources
is quite ahead of the curve here but the
federal policy that we're talking about
would really ramp up this ambition and
notably apply it to the whole country
rather than having this sort of
piecemeal approach that we've had to
date
now what my book looks at is the
backlash that has come from interest
groups and even some members of the
public although largely interest groups
against the clean energy transition and
what i show
is that fossil fuel companies and
electric utilities are resisting the
clean energy transition in a wide
variety of ways
then and the book is meant to kind of
describe
and categorize and show the tactics that
these industries are using to try to
undermine what we would call policy
feedback
so it's possible that many in this group
are familiar with the term policy
feedback but
just as a refresher typically in
political science and public policy work
we think about how politics as the
independent variable such as
the election of president biden this
fall reshapes the political landscape
and makes policy such as this clean
electricity standard
possible so we're thinking about
politics as the independent variable
and policy as the dependent variable now
we don't have to think in that way
we can think about how policy itself
such as the passage of a clean
electricity standard or renewable
portfolio standard
in a given state can reshape the
political environment by for example
creating new advocates like clean energy
companies or
bolstering environmental groups and that
they can come back
in later rounds and further expand the
policy
so we're thinking about how policy is
reshaping politics and then how politics
can then
shift to expand policy and under that
scenario we get a positive policy
feedback cycle right an
amplifying cycle where a small policy at
time one
grows over time to be a bigger policy at
time two
and that was the theory behind a lot of
these policies that
we would get a first renewable portfolio
standard in a given state
we would be able to increase that target
bring forward that timeline and then
maybe even pass one federally
but that isn't exactly how things have
played out and that's because
what i argue is that the interest groups
opposed to your policy can
actually learn through that
implementation of laws and they don't
just kind of go away
that incumbents remain in the political
environment
and that they can try to undermine
policy feedback how do they do that well
i'm going to talk about that in detail
but
some of the ways that i describe in the
book are things like lobbying
what i call implementation resistance
which is resisting policies at
implementation bodies in my case public
utility commissions
primaries and elections particularly how
the republican party has been pulled
away from climate and clean energy
through
primary challenges astroturfing and
outside lobbying as well as court cases
and if you don't know the terms
astroturfing and outside lobbying again
these are policy and political science
terms astroturfing is fake grassroots
campaigns where you pretend you're a
grassroots organization when you're not
and outside lobbying is a concept from
ken coleman which is about how interest
groups can organize the public to
amplify their own interests right so
one maybe positive example that would be
if you're a solar company that builds
rooftop solar maybe you're going to
organize your customers to lobby on
behalf of you
in a um a policy fight
okay so you probably know that bills
become laws
right but policy feedback studies
ask what happens next what happens after
a bill becomes a law
and we we are interested in looking at
how policies can reshape the political
environment
and what i argue is that during
implementation that's when
policy feedback really takes hold
because that's when
resources are redistributed between
advocates and opponents and so
uh the opponent interest groups
theoretically lose some of their power
and resources
and the supportive interest groups
theoretically grow over time
right now what do these interest groups
do well they don't just lay down and die
in the case of opponents and the
advocates might try to
expand the policy so they either go
directly
to the legislators to try to shift
policy and that would be a very
clear policy feedback cycle but as we
know from the work of for example
schneider a really important figure in
policy work
in political science they can also quote
expand the scope of conflict
by bringing in for example the public as
part of the fight
and that is something that electric
utilities and fossil fuel companies have
been doing in the case of clean energy
so i'm going to give you two examples of
that in kansas which is the headquarters
of koch industries a major fossil fuel
and petrochemical company
run by the koch brothers one of whom is
now
deceased um you know they they had a
renewable portfolio standard
and um it was doing quite well as you
can imagine kansas is a very windy state
but koch industries wanted to roll back
this policy
and so all of a sudden this group popped
up called the kansas
seniors alliance and these flyers
started going around
saying that call your representative
tell them to repeal this mandate
so terrible it's going to jack up
electricity bills for all these kansas
seniors who are struggling
so a um lawyer
was the person who actually registered
this 501c3
organization and they wanted to know you
know who was behind
this organization and so what they did
was they went to uh that lawyer and they
said hey
uh this was a journalist they said hey
uh who are you working for like who's
the kansas seniors alliance there's no
website
you know i'm just curious who's involved
here when the lawyer said oh i don't
work for the kansas seniors alliance i
work for americans for prosperity
which you may know is a kind of public
facing
front group for koch industries the
corporation
and it turns out that basically they had
formed this group on behalf of americans
for prosperity it wasn't just like a
spontaneous upwelling of kansas seniors
[Music]
now
here's an even more nefarious example of
astroturfing that comes from new orleans
in new orleans the utility entergy
wanted to build
a new gas plant and in order to do that
they had to get a permit
in this case from the city council in
new orleans
and you can see there was a city council
meeting and a lot of people showed up a
lot of people were wearing the same
shirt
they had these signs typically when you
have a grassroots
movement an organization the signs are
sort of handmade they're colorful
etc but these ones were all printed out
in a mass way
and these people got up to the podium
and they spoke and they said we want to
build this gas plant that's what we
think should happen
so some journalists went up to these
people afterwards and they said you know
hey
why do you support the gas plant and
they said oh
i don't support the gas plant i'm an out
of work actor
and i was actually paid to come to this
meeting and to speak
um up in this way and i was actually
paid an extra money
if i was given a speaking rule and it
turns out
that the utility had spent 27 000 on a
pr firm
who had gone and hired all these actors
to show up to this meeting and pretend
to be the public
and of course this raises serious
concerns about sort of democratic uh
representation and participation
when a meeting which has only a certain
amount of time and a certain amount of
space for voices
is being taken over by front groups and
i'll say this is actually happening
right now in my um community of santa
barbara
where a front group for a gas company
has been going to city council meetings
to try to block
um the electrification of new buildings
in the city
and has really been taking up time from
the public from participating and
they've also been texting
people throughout the community to
spread it for misinformation about what
this policy is about
now it's not just the public that gets
brought into these fights over clean
energy and climate action
it's also the political parties and one
of the key arguments that i make in the
in my book is that one of the reason why
we've seen polarization
specifically asymmetric polarization on
renewables
is because the republican party has been
pulled away
from renewable energy by utilities
and fossil fuel interest groups and the
way that i see that playing out in
practice
is through primaries so i'm going to
tell you the story of russ jennings a
representative
in kansas russ jennings was a republican
from the western part of the state who
was elected to the state house
and his part of the state actually
benefited a lot from the renewable
portfolio standard
he saw all these new wind projects going
into his community it was bringing in
new tax revenue employing people it was
a great thing
and so when koch industries started to
put on the agenda
the repeal of the renewable portfolio
standard he voted against it
and the interesting thing is it wasn't
just russ jennings uh the first time a
vote was held to repeal the rps in
in kansas uh as many republicans voted
to keep the policy in place
supporting renewables as voted to get
rid of it 44 to 44.
of course the democrats voted to keep it
now the next time the vote happened
which was just a few weeks later
suddenly a few less republicans voted to
keep the policy
and then a few weeks later the exact
same boat was held again and a few less
voted so we have a nice
uh longitudinal study here so to speak a
panel of the same people voting on the
same bill over time and for something
there must be something intervening
in the time periods as like a treatment
that is somehow shifting the votes of
those republicans to be anti-renewables
well we happen to know what that
treatment was because it was leaked to
the press
another representative named scott
schwab said that koch industries
through their lobbies for americans for
prosperity were going to
republican members and saying if you
don't vote the right way on this bill
we are going to primary challenger
challenge you you're going to lose your
money and you will find yourself with a
well-funded primary challenger
now you might say well it's just one
organization what does it matter if you
lose your money from koch industries
well let's think about how a republican
in the state house gets funded their
number one source of campaign financing
is the kansas uh republican party and
what is one of the top donors to the
kansas republican party
koch industries the second biggest
source of donation funds is the kansas
chamber of commerce and what's a top
donor to the kansas chamber of commerce
coke industries and the one of the third
top donors is koch industries themselves
and so if a key actor like that that has
so much political power
in your state says this is a litmus test
item
and you refuse to change your vote you
will find yourself losing your funding
and with a primary challenger and guess
what that's what happened to russ
jennings
he lost his funding and he did have a
primary challenger now
in the case of russ jennings thankfully
he won re-election in part because the
wind
industry which through policy feedback
was growing
right they actually were able to field
their own political action committee
and were able to support him so he
squeaked through but
even if these people win reelection
think about what kind of chilling signal
that spends
that sense to the caucus overall right
if you've ever read fenno for example
he writes about you know his experience
of uh
spending a lot of time with uh
politicians and seeing how paranoid they
are about
how they could be how they could lose
re-election at any given moment from an
issue arising in their district and
this is the kind of thing that really
freaks out politicians when they think
i could be primary challenged over this
and so this is how in my view we've seen
the republican party
pull away from the democratic party pull
away from the center on climate change
and really become an anti-renewables
group and it's very been very
interesting watching what's playing out
in texas
in the past week and i wrote a whole
thread about this based on my research
because texas is a major
case in my book texas was a place where
republicans were supporting renewables
in the late 90s and early 2000s in fact
this seven billion dollar spending bill
to build transmission for wind energy
was sponsored by a republican quite a
conservative one
from the panhandle and the wind energy
expansion was also sponsored by him
and yet today we see people like
governor abbott
blaming the boogeyman angry new deal and
um
wind energy and things like that when
it's not even true
and what i argue is that's because uh
there's been
a lot of lobbying from fossil fuel and
utilities
in that state to really polarize the
republican party away from action
and this is unfortunately a pattern
that's been playing out across the
country over the last
uh 15 years so you can see that in the
early 90s and and
early 2000s republican governors were
actually the ones who signed these clean
energy bills overwhelmingly such as
governor george w
bush in texas but then by 2005 we can't
find any bills that were passed
under republican leadership
and that asymmetric polarization which
is taking place at the elite level
has implications for the public because
we know
based on research from people like gabe
lens the political scientists at uc
uh berkeley that the public follows
elites right if elites like donald trump
start to say
uh climate change sorry wind turbines
cause cancer
and they're terrible and et cetera
that's going to trickle down into what
co-partisans
everyday republicans who are listening
to him are going to think about the
issue
and that's exactly what we started to
see around 2008 and 2009
now thankfully this actually has
recovered a lot in the last few years
but with the kinds of messaging we saw
last week out of texas you could you
could imagine some kind of mass
polarization amongst republicans um
happening again
so my book looks at a lot of cases as i
mentioned texas is one of the
main things that i went and studied as
part of the work also kansas and arizona
and ohio
and if you're interested in some of
these stories and you want them in a
more accessible way
i actually turned the arizona and ohio
chapters of my book into uh podcasts as
part of
this podcast that i run called a matter
of degrees which is sort of a long form
uh documentary style podcast and it
brings to life a lot of these stories so
i'd recommend folks check that out
and i've also written up some of these
things in places like fox
now i'll just point out that although
many people are probably familiar with
climate denial and how the fossil fuel
industry has
spent decades harassing scientists
spreading misinformation
etc to the tunes of billions and
billions of dollars
they this has also been perpetuated by
electric utilities
electric utilities have made a lot of
problematic decisions
in terms of wasting promoting a wasteful
energy system promoting climate denial
and working to roll back clean energy
laws
and if you're just interested in this
part of my book or you want to share it
with a class or something like that
i publish an excerpt on drill news
if you'd like to get a copy of the book
go to the oxford university press
website which is just bitly slash
scp dashbook you can use this 30
off discount code if you would like um
and then it's like cheaper
and you can share that with whoever you
want to and it also exists as an ebook
which is cheaper
if you like ebooks i like read a lot of
ebooks and you can also get an audio
book they turned it into an audio book
if that's something you're interested in
i love
audiobooks um so that's how you can get
a copy of the book and
uh yeah feel free to do that i now
want to talk in sort of the remainder of
my presentation about some work that i'm
currently doing and some recent policy
reports that i've released
i guess in the last month the first was
with sierra club
and it looks at what utilities are doing
to decarbonize their electricity supply
and the other the second was with
evergreen
and with data for progress and is really
about how can congress pass a clean
electricity standard as part of budget
reconciliation this year
so the sierra club report is called the
dirty truth about utility climate
pledges
and what we did is we looked at all the
utilities in the country
and we gave them scores and what we
found and the what was the input for the
scores
the first was are you planning to retire
coal by 2030
a lot of utilities are not planning on
doing that what are your plans to build
new gas
many utilities have a lot of plans to
build gas remember gas
fossil gas is a fossil fuel and what are
your plans to build renewables and very
few utilities have plans on that and
without
a requirement at the federal level the
reality is that most utilities will not
move fast enough so this is a snapshot
of a bunch of utilities in indiana
and you can see here that nipsco great
utility actually has plans to retire all
its coal by 2030
has plans to build no new gas and
actually has plans to
to replace four fifths of its current
electricity with renewables so that's a
very winning score there
and you can see that the the scores get
worse as we get further down um and duke
in particular
has not enough plans to retire coal is
planning to build a lot of new gas
etc so
although a lot of utilities have adopted
voluntary
clean energy pledges the point is that
they are not the same as a clean
electricity standard they're not the
same as a law
because there's no real way to enforce
them and indeed many of these utilities
that at the parent company level
meaning a lot of utilities have complex
uh holding company structures where
there's a parent company and then they
own a bunch of utilities and those
utilities are actually the ones that
make planning
decisions so southern company at the
parent company level has made plans to
um you know decarbonized by 2050
but then when their uh subsidiaries like
georgia power and alabama power
are planning to do uh what are we going
to build next
they are not taking into consideration
that parent company's pledge
and they're literally saying in
proceedings no we don't have to do that
that's southern that's not
us so when you have a corporate pledge
that doesn't even
apply to the planning entities within
the organization what is the point of
the pledge
and we can see that very clearly here
because as you can see
right now utilities are not planning to
build enough renewables if we look at
the 2019 coal and gas
generation that's up to 1300 million
megawatt hours and yet we're only seeing
about 250 million uh megawatt
megawatt hours of planned to clean
energy editions by 2030 so there's
no plan to decarbonize the electricity
system without government policy
[Music]
particularly when it comes to coal plant
retirement you can see that the
utilities in our report that we gave f's
to which by the way we graded on a curve
so you only
had to get 18 or more to be out of the f
range because that was the median
um score you can see that the utilities
getting f's in our report have basically
no plan to retire their coal they are
only planning to retire seven percent by
2030
and the utilities that are doing much
better in the a and b category have a
lot of plans to retire their coal
so we know it's possible to be making
progress just too few utilities are
actually doing it
if you're interested in looking up
utilities we only look
at the largest oil and gas um
holders in not only gas sorry coal and
gas
holders in the country so it's not every
utility
it's um 50 parent companies and 79
subsidiaries
but your your utility might be listed
here and otherwise you can just look at
other utilities and you can get a sense
of
what exactly are they planning because
although this information exists it has
never been compiled in this way and so
you'd have to be you know in a specific
state in a specific rate case to know
what for example
um uh florida power and light is doing
right but now you can actually just go
to this dashboard and look it all up in
one place
and i think that's really a very
powerful thing so i'd encourage folks to
check that out as a resource
now the other thing that i'm working
very actively on is the federal policy
opportunity we have before us right now
so we have an unprecedented chance to
scale up the
leadership at the state and local level
in 2021 with comprehensive climate
legislation
and the way this is going to happen is
through um budget reconciliation
so for those of you who have been
following this the current cobit package
is going to be passed through
the fiscal year 20 budget reconciliation
process
and then after that's completed maybe in
march
uh there's going to be another package
that will be
the biden buildback better agenda and
that will include a lot of climate and
clean energy uh
investments and we're working very hard
to figure out how to do a clean
electricity standard as part of that
package
these are just the pledges that bind
made key pledges on standards
key pledges on investments and key
pledges on
justice specifically ensuring that 40 of
these investments are going into
disadvantaged communities
[Music]
so is this doable can we actually clean
up our electricity system fast the
answer is yes
if you go to the 2035report.com it's
just 2035report.com
there's an amazing study which shows
what's possible and they show that we
can actually get to
90 percent clean by 2035 and save
customers money
and that's because the coal plants that
are operating in this country are
actually operating at a loss
but because many utilities are
monopolies there's no market-based
signal to put pressure on those coal
plants to retire and so utilities are
just charging customers excess money
to keep those coal plants open many coal
plants could be replaced
tomorrow with a wind energy plant and
save customers money
and of course their health and our air
and our climate and everything else and
you don't have to just take that from me
the ceo of nextera a major uh electric
uh
power uh uh builder in this country
has said there is not a single economic
coal plant in this country full stop
period so this is a fact so we released
this report it's called a roadmap to 100
clean electricity by 2035 and it talks
through a lot of
the considerations in this approach and
what we really argue is that the next
two years are critical
anybody who follows federal policy knows
that we have as
kingdom would have told us of policy
windows we get these moments of
opportunity and they don't come by very
often we haven't had one for a decade on
climate and energy
and this really creates a big
opportunity to increase the pace and
scale of clean energy deployment
and the fact is as i've mentioned this
is really uh going to build
on the leadership of states uh it's also
very popular
and it's very practical approach so this
isn't something we've never done before
already more than one in three americans
live in a place targeting 100
clean power in the report we get
we go through a lot of details about how
this can be done through budget
reconciliation
the basic rules of budget reconciliation
or that the policy has to be primarily
budgetary it either needs to be about
expenditures
revenues and or debt so the way we think
about passing a policy like this is
basically saying
if you're doing the right thing utility
if you're building four to five
percentage points a year
of clean power you get money we will
give you
financial resources from the federal
government if you're not doing the right
thing
you don't get that money or you get less
of it like you're missing your target
and you have to pay an alternative
compliance penalty a payment
for every unit of power that you were
short so that's basically expenditures
and revenues into the federal government
and it's actually quite different from
state policies that involve a lot of
credits and trading and all this kind of
stuff it's very simple
you get paid for doing the right thing
and building new clean
and you get punished if you don't do the
right thing and the the
important thing about standard over and
above just an investment strategy which
by the way the investments
which would be the production tax credit
extended for 10 years and turn into a
direct pay mechanism
that's really the foundation of all this
work that's necessary
but if you just give money and you put
no standards or requirements on it
we will not move fast enough we have to
say that you have to not just take that
money but you have to build enough clean
power at the pace and scale that's
necessary
there are a lot of other things we have
to do in this package i won't get into
them here
um but the the report does if you're
interested
and i'll just say that we partnered with
data for progress on this and they did a
lot of polling on clean electricity
standards they're very popular
particularly amongst democrats and
independents
but even if you add up the sort of don't
knows for republicans you're getting to
about 50
so you know it's not a very unpopular
policy when it comes to
uh republicans either i'll also say that
we have some examples of corporate
leadership like
google which is aiming for 100 clean
electricity by 2030 in
real time at all facilities you know a
lot of corporations today say they're
100
clean but what they're doing is they're
buying credits renewable electricity
certificates
wrecks and they're saying that you know
my facility is powered by clean power
but
that's not real right that's not really
those electrons coming to that facility
or coming from
zero carbon resources um and so what
google is trying to do is actually
deliver
that stuff to all his facilities real
time by 2030. and that would be huge
because as far as i understand google's
the largest energy consumer in the
country
[Music]
we also have some nascent utility
leadership emerging on this and i think
we're at this inflection point where
utilities will hopefully stop becoming
opponents to the clean energy
transition and we'll see the massive
opportunity for them
not just in cleaning up the existing
supply but in building out
huge amounts of new power to power
transportation
buildings parts of heavy industry right
the scale of the electricity system is
going to grow enormously and utilities
should see an opportunity there
in colorado essentially all the
utilities are committed in law
to 80 clean power by 2030. and as i
mentioned that is directly on the path
to 100 clean by 2035
and jared polis the governor of colorado
was one of the people to endorse our
reports based on his own leadership
um i do a lot of climate advocacy if
that was not obvious
i run a podcast called the matter of
degrees
it has lots of interesting episodes
about utilities and other things
and i also uh contributed to this book
called all we can save which is a really
nice collection
from women across the movement about
climate action
and thanks so much and i'll stop sharing
my slides now and i'm happy to take
questions
thank you so much for a great
presentation um so to get started
everybody as i said
um i think using the raise hands
function would be
the most straightforward way to take
questions um
i know that we had at least one that
came in the chat that i think was from
um daniel i don't know whether uh daniel
you'd like to actually ask your question
or i could ask it for you
i will go ahead um so this question had
to do and this is probably helpful
conceptually for everybody um this
question
has to do with sort of the difference
maybe between
potential capacity of renewable energy
sources
versus the actual sort of effective
capacity on a day-to-day basis so his
question specifically had to do with
weather sources like solar or wind
always have sort of the maximum capacity
possible or whether in a place like
connecticut maybe where it's not as
sunny
does that potentially reduce the overall
contribution to the energy grid that
some sources could give
so i imagine that this is sort of a
common thing that
um any discussion of renewable energy is
about sort of how much has to be built
to meet system capacity so if you could
talk
maybe a little bit about that
yeah sure so when we talk about any
energy source
we can talk about capacity meaning the
size of the projects that that is built
so
we would talk about like a two megawatt
wind turbine or like a 500 megawatt coal
plant or like a one
gigawatt which is a thousand megawatts
nuclear plant something like that right
now each of those sources has a capacity
factor
which is how many hours of the year is
this plant actually delivering
power and that's how we get from
megawatts in capacity
to megawatt hours in generation
and so the renewable portfolio standard
or clean energy standard is on
generation
it's not on capacity right and the
reality is we have to build a lot more
capacity for wind and solar because they
have a lower
uh capacity factor so typically uh
wind might have a capacity factor
depending on the wind resource
aka how windy it is of like 30
or 40 or 50 typically a
nuclear plant which is usually running
all the time does not shut down has a
capacity factor of like 98
or something like that and often a gas
plant
maybe has one of like 80 percent or 90
percent
um so that's what we mean by sort of
capacity factors and so
we'll have to build a lot of wind and
solar and depending on its location
it will have higher capacity factors so
if you're in a more northern latitude
you know you put a given size like a 10
kilowatt array of solar on your roof
the amount of kilowatt hours or megawatt
hours it will produce will be lower
because it's not as sunny there and so
the bigger issue is not so much the
capacity factor of a given resource
it's what we would call intermittency
and integration
so how do we make sure that we have
enough supply
at every given second everywhere as
demand because that's how the
electricity system works
what was happening in texas last week
is that there was too much demand in
part because when it got cold and nobody
has insulated houses in texas texas
actually is like bottom of the nation in
energy efficiency
people were using a lot more power and
then
all these plants were tripping offline
right and so what happens is when supply
and demand get out of whack that's very
problematic you either have to
shed load meaning reduce demand
or you have to increase supply and in
texas they couldn't increase supply
there was nothing else to bring online
all these plants were offline they were
frozen they didn't have
all these gas plants they didn't have
gas on site they didn't
they didn't weatherize them they didn't
have any kind of alternative
fuel on site and notably el paso
electric which is another
utility not operating in the
restructured market of ercot
they had weatherized their plants
because of a an event i think in 2011
they had stored other gas another
resource on site i think it was like
diesel or oil so that they had another
fuel and they didn't go offline so
you know that is really about how does
the grid
maintain reliability how do we integrate
all these resources
and as we get higher and higher levels
of what we would call intermittent
resources which is wind and solar
that are not around all the time we need
to have more transmission
to connect parts of the country for
where you know if the midwest has a
bunch of windiness but the coasts don't
we can connect those two and we'll have
extra supply over here
and and less supply over there and then
we can spread that out
so that's why transmission is so
important because it allows for this
geographic sharing of resources
and it's also why things like offshore
wind are so important
because offshore wind has a higher
capacity factor because the wind is
blowing more
consistently in the offshore area than
it is on land
so and of course this is why batteries
are really important so that we can
store
power so that in any given moment when
the
let's say uh sun goes behind a cloud and
the wind files down
we can still be drawing on power so
all of our grid is going to have to
become more flexible
and more resilient but that's what we
have to do no matter what i mean
fossil fuels themselves are making our
grid less resilient because they're
leading to climate change
which is leading to extreme weather
events like heat waves
and wildfires that are destabilizing our
grid so we can't continue in the system
that we've been
in fundamentally that's creating an
enormous amount of
instability in our electricity system
through the impacts of climate change
itself
so hopefully that's a little bit helpful
and if folks are interested in start
getting a 101 on energy
there's a book that's quite old but i
think is still quite good and it's free
on the internet
it's called sustainable energy without
the hot air and it's by david makai
you can download that and you can learn
some basic facts about
some of these things that i'm talking
about and kind of get the 101
of different energy sources
sounds great thanks so much um so
another question that has been
put in our chat that i'll read and maybe
if sebastian
um who's asking it would like to follow
up um so he asks um your analysis
um today seems to focus a lot on
investor-owned utilities
and he's wondering whether your work um
looks at public owned utilities as well
and or energy production and their
progress on renewable goals and maybe
whether there's a distinction
yeah so um the reality is that
there's a view amongst some in the left
that public power will be better than if
we so we already have in this country
about four different types of utilities
one is the investor owned well i think i
have to do more actually than just four
but
there are private corporations sometimes
they're vertically integrated in which
case we call them investor owned
utilities
sometimes they're operating in
restructured markets like in ercot but
they're
companies making profits okay that's the
first type then we have a type called
public power
municipal utilities these operate
typically in cities and they sort of
predate
a lot of the larger utilities that um
expanded to become private companies
and uh they operate outside of public
utility commissions and they're often
overseen by city councils
um so in california we have sacramento
uh sacramento municipal utility district
in on texas there's austin energy
so there are different places that have
kind of city
municipal utilities now nobody has ever
studied the electricity mix of these
different
utilities i have started that project
it's very hard to do
and overall i think municipal utilities
have slightly cleaner power but i think
it's partially because of where they
operate and the fact that they're kind
of smaller and city based
we have a third type which is called
rural electric co-ops
these are utilities that came out of the
new deal
and i write a little bit about that in
my book and there's a book that will
come out
maybe in a year or two by abby spinak
who's a lecturer at the harvard graduate
school of design which talks about the
whole history of the new deal and the
rural electric coops
anyway these are co-ops that were put in
places where um
private companies were not expanding the
grid and they still exist today
co-ops are some of the dirtiest energy
suppliers in the country
they have very dirty energy mixes a lot
of coal
and there are big challenges right now
for a lot of co-ops in terms of how do
we clean up their electricity mix and
you can see that playing out in states
like colorado
and then we have also federal power
authorities like the tennessee valley
authority
the tva is a terrible utility it's
extremely dirty
the tva is actually one of them that we
study in our sierra club report if
you're interested in looking at it
they have enormous amounts of coal they
are planning to build enormous amounts
of gas and they are not building
renewables at a fast pace by any means
so
uh in the in the conclusion of my book
in the conclusion chapter i
get into this discussion of sort of
public power and sort of changing who
owns these things and changing their
governance structure and will that solve
a problem
and my general view is no it will not um
there have been
attempts in boulder colorado to break
off from excel
for like a decade it hasn't even
happened um
and excel meanwhile has pulled ahead and
is one of the
you know fastest renewable energy
utilities in the
country now maybe that's in part because
of the activism of those groups putting
pressure on that utility so
even if campaigns lose to
create public power there can still be
utility in these campaigns
because they can um put pressure on the
utility system to shift
but i think that um the view that
ownership is a panacea for our problems
is just not borne out empirically when
we look at
the massive different types of utilities
that exist today and the interesting
thing about the utility sector is we
have so many types of utilities that we
can
kind of see and practice does is this
associated with clean power or things
that we want and
in general it's not and it's been
interesting too you know watching the
criticism of ercot a restructured
electricity system
in the wake of the crisis there's
obviously some downsides to restructured
electricity systems and
the texas restructured system is
actually quite restructured there's also
retail choice and that's in part why
people are getting such insane bills
and anyway but there's also benefits to
restructured system namely
remember how i told you about those
uneconomic coal plants in vertically
integrated monopoly areas that have not
been restructured
these utilities maintain these coal
plants because there's no pressure on
them from market signals to shut down
so some advocates for clean energy
actually want more markets because then
we can get signals into the system
to shut down coal plants so it's just
way more complicated than you think
i'm trying to say about the utility
industry and there aren't really simple
answers and i'm very open
to you know public power i know
advocates uh
who are really into it who have been
disappointed that i'm not more for their
campaigns and i really like those people
and i understand what they're doing
but i just don't think empirically that
this
is uh the path forward and let's also
keep in mind that we have like a decade
to clean up the electricity system for
15 years and
changing the structure of these
utilities will take a long time
and it's probably just not um on the
timeline that's that's a
possible when it comes to cleaning up
the system so that is my view
others may have different views um but
yeah i also write about that in the
conclusion of my book
great so we have one um question and
excuse me
that's raised right now old a bold
questioner yes
several more in the chat but i'm gonna
go to the raised hand um first if that
raise your hands people you'll get to go
faster
right um thank you very much for the
wonderful like um
information that you've provided i just
have a quick question about um
what kind of strategy like um just to
help i guess me understand
what are the strategies that um these i
guess uh
util like this like companies have in
mind when they like misinform the public
they they like publicly pressure um
well at least the um right now in the
age of like technology it's very easy to
publicly expose their like acts to
pressure like politicians
so they're taking like risky moves which
like come with expenses of their own
and also hurt their like reputation
politically and with the consumers
so what's like their long-term like
strategy or like
do they plan on like sustaining
something like this indefinitely and
just keep burning money to like lobby
and a push for
false i guess like misinformation
campaigns or what what exactly do they
have in their minds when they
come up with a strategy of like adopting
change or just continuing
and pushing back change like can you try
and help me better understand like
what's
like out there those are great that's a
great question yeah
well the thing is that these companies
that i'm talking about
apart from the utilities if it's oil and
gas or gas utilities i mean apart from
the electric utilities
they're really in death they're in a
death uh life or death situation it's an
existential
fight that they're having over this
policy and so you're right there are
costs to doing these things the
reputation will be tarnished
so the the thing i talked about in
california with socalgas
my my gas utility they created a front
group called californians for balanced
energy solutions
they texted maybe 20 of the people in
santa barbara we don't know that's just
an estimate from one environmental group
um they spread misinformation and they
got like hundreds of letters written to
the city council
completely uninformed about this ban on
gas
in new buildings and now why did they do
that that got them a lot of bad press i
wrote about it
others have written about it well they
did it because if they
lose gas hookups and new buildings they
lose their growth
they're a private corporation right they
have to
well they're not private they're
shareholder owned right they have to
make growth they have to show a profits
they have to show some kind of future
trajectory
and so they they're fighting to the
death they're kind of like a wounded
animals what i'm trying to say
and so they um are willing to tarnish
their reputation
and engage in all kinds of dirty tactics
because they
they'd otherwise think that they're
gonna die and they're trying to
forestall
that timeline um so for and
it's quite bad in california right now
the california
public utility commission public
advocates office is like
has fines out to them for this they have
i think subpoenas trying to get more
information from what they're up to
it's quite a bad public thing there was
a recent report about it in npr
and there's been reporting in the la
times and mother jones and other places
um
but it's worth it for these gas
companies because
we are trying to put them out of
business fundamentally and so
they are willing to tarnish their
reputation and to engage in these sort
of
dark campaigns to try to stay alive and
i will say it does work to some extent
i went to the city council meeting for
the santa barbara city council after
this misinformation campaign and
one of the city councillors was even
though he knew
based on the reporting i had done the
staff at the city council talked about
it
other city councils talked about it and
the people who showed up for the meeting
the front group came as did socalgas but
then a lot of advocates came
and talked about how this was
misinformation and it was
uh they texted all these people but even
still
it's like he fell for it you know
because he got letters from people in
his constituency and that freaked him
out
right so what they're trying to do is
mobilize the public use this
astroturfing campaign because that is
something that scares politicians
the same kind of thing we saw in new
orleans with entergy
that example i gave so you're right it
does tarnish their reputation it's not a
really great long-term sustainable
strategy for their company
but fundamentally these companies are
not sustainable companies they don't
have a long-term strategy period
so this is just more of uh the
unfortunate same
when it comes to these companies i think
um
there's a follow-up question actually on
that
so go ahead right sorry um i meant to
ask you that's like a two-part
question right man so the the second
part is like
what's like preventing them from just
you know painting their strategy and um
figuring out maybe a way for them to
exit the like
gas industry and move towards renewables
i mean they're already spending money
right so it's like some cost for them
why not rebrand right
yeah so that's the kind of thing that
everybody's been saying forever
a lot of these companies have uh sort of
asset specificity and uh human capital
specificity that's pretty difficult to
just pivot into doing something else
one of the things they did in um in san
francisco over these gas fights
is that they gave a contract to the gas
company
which includes a lot of pipe fitters
right because you're laying down pipe
for gas
to build water infrastructure and
upgrade water infrastructure because
that's the same kind of thing
right you're building pipes for gas
you're building pipes for water
so there is some ability potentially to
retrain people or to have the industry
pivot
but some industries are not very
pivotable
if all you've been doing is selling a
fossil fuel in the case of fossil gas
well what else are you supposed to do
some utilities have a utility side and a
gas side
and those ones can see a route out
because they can ramp down their gas
side while ramping up
their um electric utility side right
but a lot of them just don't see an exit
plan and
uh this is also why we need transition
funds to help workers out to help
transition these industries because
they're not going to be
around in the long term and uh
you know one of the things they do is
they lie they say we're going to have
renewable
natural gas or they don't you know this
is not true
i think the estimate i always forget it
but it's like
six percent of the current gas supply uh
can be done with renewable natural gas
let me fact check myself while i talk
and um you know if if we only have a
very limited
amount of renewable natural gas
uh 13 sorry 13 of the existing demand
can be done by renewable natural gas
we only have a certain amount that we
can produce this is by the way from like
landfills
um cafes concentrated animal feeding
operations
you know factory farms meat basically we
only have a certain amount of
that kind of gas we should probably use
it for the sectors that are hard to
decarbonize and where we're still going
to need gas
like industry not in our homes where by
the way
using gas for cooking and heating is
literally poisoning us even though we
don't recognize that and there's more
and more research coming out
showing that the air quality impacts of
gas stoves are terrible they increase
the risk of childhood asthma 42
i mean it's really quite bad the air
pollution impacts of gas in our homes
so we probably shouldn't be using gas in
our homes anyway and if we have some
renewable gas
that's going to need to be used in
sectors where we really can't
decarbonize other ways
so anyway yeah it's not a happy story
this is why we need transition funding
one of the things that the biden
administration did in their executive
orders on climate
was that they set up a committee or
dialogue
on transition funding to try to think
about some of these sectors in our
economy
that aren't going away and try to do a
kind of planned
uh transition for those communities and
for those workers
thanks so much um i'm i have some
questions in the chat
that i um definitely will get to but i'm
gonna go next to sam
hello uh hey leah thanks for your talk
and discussion
um i'm curious to ask a question that's
a little bit outside the scope of the
book but extending a little more to
contemporary climate politics about
um basically politics around a green new
deal as opposed to
uh policies about you know like rules
and caps and standards
um i guess a green new deal could mean
different things but uh a policy that is
about investment in
things energy jobs transit etc and i'm
curious from the state level
particularly
um if you think all climate advocates in
all states decided to pursue state
renewed deals instead of
standards if you think um like similar
opposition would be met
but different active supporting
organized or unorganized constituencies
um yeah yeah well the first thing i'll
say is that
another way of thinking about the green
new deal framework is standards
investment justice
and so standards do are not outside of
the purview of a green new deal
framework and
a lot of the ways that people tend to
think about what's outside are more like
cap and trade carbon pricing sort of
market-based mechanisms to
environmental policy the reason why we
can't just do an investment only
approach
is because we will not get where we need
to go at the pace and scale that's
necessary
what all the modeling shows is that you
give money
but it doesn't get you to the deployment
that you need and so we have to have
some kind of requirement
to mop up at the end of the day and say
it's great that you're building stuff
but you actually need to build
enough stuff and there with climate
change
there's a huge difference and i think
this is one of the fundamental
contributions of the green new deal
thinking about the scale and the scope
of the problem the pace that's necessary
um not just sort of saying oh we'll do a
little climate policy we'll put a price
on carbon we'll hope that it reduces
some emissions
we actually say here's how much
emissions we have to reduce here's how
much clean power we need here's when we
need it by that was one of the key
things in terms of reframing it around
2030 in particular
and i will say too that the green new
deal framework resolution included
clean power as a really key um part of
the approach
so i think that the approach with
standards
investment and justice is really the way
forward and that builds on the green new
deal framework
and you know states can't really do that
because they don't have the power of the
purse like the federal government does
and of course in this exact moment that
we find ourselves in right now they're
in terrible financial shape
a lot of states and cities and so this
piecemeal approach that we've had
which is not getting us where we need to
go um is not going to be able to
leverage that investment so
as much as i think a lot of groups can
get around
investments and be like yeah that's all
it's all it's all carrots
but at the end of the day there has to
be a stick there has to be something to
say
and if you move too slowly you're in
trouble a carrots only approach will not
move us at the pace as necessary and we
can design some of those
sticks to make sure that they're not um
imposing costs on consumers or um
you know creating more inequality right
like we don't have to have sticks be
like a carbon price that is very
consumer facing costs
we can have them be designed in other
ways where we're not pushing the cost of
the transition on to everyday people so
that that really is the way
that a bunch of us have been thinking
and writing and working on the the
standards approach
is really in line with um sort of the
green new gl standards investment
justice uh framework
um another question that we have in our
chat um
is about sort of the different types of
renewable energy um that we might need
and so this question basically
is talking about how maybe solar and
wind especially need obviously a lot of
land mass or water mass for offshore
um wind areas um and so what would the
role potentially be
for nuclear power i mean any large
renewable energy
revolution yeah nuclear the thing i
spend so much of my time
either people loving it or hating it and
that's my time a lot of the time you
know the reality is that within clean
nuclear counts it's not a carbon
emitting resource but the reality too
is that we're not building new nuclear
really apart from like mogul one plant
um we are likely to be
losing some of the share losing the
share would could be very bad
in terms of if it's replaced by gas
which is what often happens
um so if we need to be ramping up
renewables so much more
and we probably need to keep nuclear
online to the extent that we
can in order to extend the timeline
to figure out how we're going to get to
80 90 100 percent
renewables without nuclear potentially
so the the hardest part of nuclear is
actually its cost
it really struggles to compete on cost
and so
i don't necessarily see a kind of
nuclear revolution coming down the pipe
nor do i see a clean electricity
standard
you know propping up nuclear or anything
like that what what a clean electricity
standard will do
is not allow retiring nuclear to be
replaced by gas
it will require that if you fall behind
on your target you have to make that
up with clean stuff and continue to make
progress on the pace that's necessary
because not only do we not want nuclear
to be
replaced with gas we want to be replaced
with renewables we also don't want
retiring nuclear to put us farther
behind the timeline that's necessary so
the standard can do all of those things
by basically saying here's the
trajectory you're on you have to stay on
that trajectory
if you shut down nuclear plants you got
to make up for that and you got to keep
staying on the trajectory so
that's really the approach that we have
been developing
um and you know i understand that some
people are very pro-nuclear and i am not
anti-nuclear um
but i think there are real barriers to
nuclear in terms of public acceptance
cost etc um so i don't i don't
necessarily see
a lot of nuclear coming down the pipe i
know others like bill gates disagree
um and who knows maybe we will need it
because
it is a higher energy density meaning
you don't need as much land to do it and
as we get to higher and higher levels of
renewables we could end up seeing huge
fights
over resources in terms of well why are
you putting a transmission line in my
backyard why are you putting a wind
turbine
and you know there are real trade-offs
real material trade-offs in the energy
transition and so if people don't want
these wind and solar projects everywhere
um you know then nuclear may have to be
something that's considered as a society
but so far
people are pretty anti-nuclear so i
don't think that that is the trade-off
that will be made
so another question that i have in our
queue um that i'll read
it seems there is a potential conflict
between the 2035
target of a zero carbon grid
and the 2050 target of a net zero
economy
if states start electrifying transport
in buildings now
perhaps meeting the 2035 target will be
harder
if they do focus only on grit
decarbonization
the 2050 target will get even more out
of reach with a late start on
electrification
um how do you think this will play out
or maybe
should play out i mean we don't have
some insane electrification pace that's
going on right now we need to be real
about where we're at i mean i have an
electric vehicle and i am electrifying
my home but the vast majority of people
are not doing that
so we can say that electrification is
coming any moment and we'll make it
really hard in the next 10 years
and of course the package will include
incentives to get that stuff going
but we are not at a point when it comes
to ev
adoption or uh building electrification
where we have to stress about this at
this moment
um i wish we were to be honest you know
of course it would make it harder from a
grid electrification perspective but
we're not at that
moment keep in mind too that even if
let's say
we fall behind on electricity
decarbonization because demand is
surging because of evs and
um a home electrification building
electrification that's not a bad thing
because we have to think about the
overall
energy sorry carbon intensity of the
energy system of the economy
and what we already know based on
research from rmi and lots of other
academics is that
pretty much everywhere in the country
electrifying buildings electrified cars
is a win
you win in terms of producing carbon so
um
you know if we somehow slow down the
pace of the electricity system
decarbonization but
speed up the pace of transportation in
buildings it's going to be a net win
right now the only sector that's been
decarbonizing
is electricity right so and the only
viable pathway to decarbonizing
transportation in buildings
and getting rid of the oil and gas chunk
is electrification
so these things are not in tension
they're really in tandem
as we move faster on electrification we
got to build more stuff
but it also is a way for utilities to
come on board because they're going to
see a massive opportunity in building
all this stuff
serving more load um i i just briefed a
utility group this morning and said
this is the biggest opportunity if
samuel insult and thomas edison were
alive today they'd be like holy
we could build all this new stuff it's
amazing and so it's like a once in a
century opportunity
um so i do think that utilities are
about to flip and become allies which
will be amazing
um and electrification is really the key
to that uh
shift in their position it's really
interesting um so
i would encourage folks to keep
submitting questions um or or even
better raise your hands um but i'm gonna
take a prerogative and ask one of my own
here
so i know we have some american politics
and graduate students in the audience in
particular
and i think um certainly one of the most
intriguing things about your book
on a theoretical to me is the move you
make to sort of
take on some of the conventional wisdom
about policy feedback
path dependence the idea that
policy feedback could be short-circuited
as you say
so i was wondering if you could talk a
little bit about sort of
where your theoretical insight into that
came from
um how you noticed this in climate and
energy policy in particular
um and sort of what it was like to be
working on this project that maybe took
a very different approach to sort of
i think one of the classic themes of
political science and especially
apd yeah so i had two people on my
committee
andrea campbell who's a very important
scholar in the policy feedback space
and judy laser who is now passed away
and who was a really important um
environmental politics scholar and uh
judy in particular
had gone to a lot of workshops in the
late 90s at harvard when
kkv was being written and she was really
into
uh sort of that approach where you're
sort of selecting with variation like
you would a regression where you're like
here's a case where false feedback
happened here's a case where policy
feedback didn't happen and you're trying
to like tease out the differences
and so the early setup of my project was
in that way because she really believed
in that framework
um the nice thing about that is that it
allowed me to look at kind of the more
unusual cases
the cases where things don't go to plan
and in that way kind of
look at the scope conditions around
policy feedback in a more critical way
right like under what conditions do we
get this lock in
and is it is it deterministic is it
really path dependence or are there
forces at work trying to undermine that
lock
in and so it's not as if my book is
saying
this is the most likely outcome for
clean energy standards i think a lot of
people read it and they somehow assume
that's what
i'm saying no garbage taxes and other
policy approaches have probably way more
backlash than
clean energy standards do and i look at
the cases where the feedback doesn't
take place so it's not
representative there are cases like
california where it's a
positive cycle or even colorado new
mexico new york all those places i
looked at that's the modal or
even the the likeliest outcome
but by looking at the cases where what
we don't predict will happen
you know um i think that it gives us a
lot of insight in the forces moving
against policy feedback and the force is
moving against lock-in
and help us understand sort of organized
combat
contestation in politics interest group
capture all these things that i think
play out a lot
even in the cases where things are going
to play we still have interest group
capture there it's just
normatively in line with what we'd like
to see in the world right so
um yeah the project definitely evolved
and if you read my dissertation which is
available online and some people still
cite you'll see that there are different
cases in it
they are more uh set up in terms of a
kkv approach
and i i think i moved away a lot of from
that in the final
um book and you know andrew campbell has
written a lot about how
you know the policy feedback cases tend
to be
i don't know if selecting on the
dependent variable is the right way of
putting it but people look at successful
cases of lock-in right they tell the
happier stories and so
one of the things i wanted to do here
was look at the more depressing stories
even though they're not the modal
outcome i think it's really important
that we look
at the the cases that don't conform to
our theories as well
um so if i can follow up on that with a
with another
very political science-oriented question
which again i think many in this
audience will appreciate
um another of the concepts that you
introduce in your book that i
particularly find intriguing is this
idea of the fog of
the a fog of enactment on a policy
i wondered if you could um elaborate a
little bit on
what that is and why it matters so much
particularly that move again
from the actual legislation maybe
ambiguities in it
to the contestation over implementation
yeah so i think there's a puzzle for
policy feedback theory which is that
if we have incumbent opponents and they
have perfect information they know
exactly
what's going on why would they ever let
a policy pass that would undermine their
power
right why would they do that and yet
policies pass that
undermine incumbent's power fairly
regularly
and so what i argue in the book is that
incumbents do not have perfect
information that
in fact no political actors whether it's
policy makers their staff
interest groups the public they don't
know what legislation is going to do
during the negotiation process and i
came to that based on a lot of
interviews with people
making laws in various places interest
groups trying to influence laws and even
looking at statements from people like
nancy pelosi
and in sort of the congressional context
and so i have quotes from like fossil
fuel lobbyists who are extremely
powerful and in the case of texas
literally like maintain
a desk in the relevant senator's office
okay very strong relationships
and yet they said if we knew that the
policy would have done this we would
have blocked
it right because when policies are
written
on paper it's um it's very
ambiguous what they're going to do in
practice and one of the things if you
read my book in the second chapter i did
a survey of state legislators and
staffers
and i asked them like how often did
policies do what you think that you
thought they were going to do and
especially in the climate and energy
space i found that a lot of staffers and
legislators said that they just didn't
do what they expected a lot of the time
and so implementation is where a lot of
the ambiguity in laws is ironed out
sometimes that ambiguity is left in laws
intentionally in a way that um douglas
arnold writes about sort of in
traceability where you say
i don't want to be held responsible for
whatever the outcome is so let's not put
it in statute and let's punt it to the
implementing agency to make that
decision
um other times you know you're not
really sure what policy is going to do
your your you know people are writing
legislative text on the fly you know
especially these days in both the state
and the federal context
these bills stretch to the hundreds
thousands of pages
people don't even know what's in them
when they're voting on them you see this
more and more and more and so
that's where this ambiguity comes in
it's it's funny i tell the story of
um i think i tell the story in the book
of
the trump tax cuts they initially passed
the bill
i don't remember through which chamber
and it included something that
accidentally would have actually reduced
um
the corporate um uh
you know the amount of taxes that
corporations have to pay
it would have made their tax rate go up
essentially
and that wasn't what they wanted to
happen but they actually passed the bill
before
folks read the bill and they said oh
gosh we got to go back and re-pass the
bill and so they re-passed the bill to
fix that problem right
there's there's always so much um uh
pressure in congress about you know the
timeline of how we're going to get this
thing passed there's two chambers
involved it's a very complex negotiating
space and so
in the book i describe all these factors
that make this ambiguity uncertainty and
the fog of enactment stronger things
like new policies
very complex bills technical policy
domains etc
um so yeah i think that this really does
reflect how policy making happens
and you know now that i'm somewhat
engaged in the policy making process
myself
it certainly feels how it is happening
nobody really feels like they know
what's going on
including interest groups and
politicians and their staff so
uh it's way more ambiguous as a space
and and you know if you've ever read
legislative text
it's legal it's very complicated and
hard to understand what it does
different parts of it can interact with
other parts of it and critically
parts of federal law can interact with
parts of state law so when we have
jurisdiction across
federal and state areas that are shared
you do one thing at the federal level
and suddenly it causes these
consequences when a state policy passes
that interacts with it
right so this is why we are operating in
a very complex
environment and um i think that
oftentimes interest groups don't know
what's going to happen and they get
caught off guard
and that's how we can kind of explain
the beginning of a policy feedback
process when
incumbents exist and should be opposed
to that policy ever passing in the first
place
um so speaking of your own advocacy and
public engagement in this area um i
thought it would be good
especially to conclude and we have both
graduate and undergraduate students that
i know are deeply passionate about
these issues first if maybe you could
tell us a little bit
about how you originally became
interested both as a scholar
and as an advocate in climate change and
energy policy
yeah sure i write about this in the book
all we can save which is a nice
collection of essays um when i was an
undergrad i got involved in an energy
conservation campaign trying to get
people to save energy
like as a psychology major and i just at
the end of that felt that it wasn't a
big enough lever
that if we really wanted to tackle
climate change and solve our problems
we had to work on the level of policy
and so that's what i've been
focusing more and more on in of course i
initially
studied people making these big changes
and it was fascinating interviewing
some of the advocates who you know
managed to get into law these sweeping
changes like a seven billion dollar
transmission investment and so many
times uh
that quote like never doubt that a small
group of committed people can make
change is the only thing that ever has
is very true like you might feel like
what can i ever do
um and you know you have to build your
career and develop your networks and
everything else
but it is very true that dedicated
people who show up
and who engage in the process can really
deeply shape
policy and i learned that by
interviewing in my book
all these people who made that happen or
failed to make that happen but got close
and that i think has really inspired me
to say
well you know we have an opportunity
right now
i have skills and ability to support
that opportunity and i'm going to do
that
and one of the skills that i have is
that i can communicate very well to lots
of different audiences i can make a
technical area
understandable to people and so that's
one of the things that i lend to this
effort whether that's
you know speaking or doing podcasts um
you know writing op-eds making things
understandable to people
and the other thing that i do well is
connect people together
and so i often think of myself as like a
yenta
to the climate movement where people
reach out to me all the time
and one thing we can do is organize
right we can connect people with other
people we can make connections
we can um by working with others get new
things done
and and because i've been very flexible
and not seen my career
as i write academic papers and that's it
um i've been able to for example write
that report with sierra club
which just came out of some
conversations we were having about some
academic work i was doing
and interestingly i abandoned the
academic paper because i felt it wasn't
really
relevant enough and moving fast enough
and then i wrote this policy report
instead with the ngo
so you know we have choices that we can
make about how
practical and applied we want our work
to be and at least as somebody who works
in climate change and energy in the
urgency of now
i feel that my work should be as
practical as possible
and that's really how i orient myself
so i think i think your answer here has
given us some insight into this
but i'm curious if you have any specific
advice that you would give
and and maybe also whether it might be
different to
undergraduate students or graduate
students um interested in climate and
energy politics and policy specifically
well i would say um one thing that i did
is i took a lot of interdisciplinary
coursework throughout my education at
the undergrad master's
another master's phd level i took
engineering
toxicology chemistry um
you know management finance economics
policy politics uh all kinds of stuff
and
hydrology carbon capture and
sequestration of course
lots of classes on energy and
electricity and
by taking such a bra and psychology by
taking such a broad
swath of training that really has set me
up well to understand the climate and
energy problem deeply
because i understand you know
biogeochemistry on a basic level i was
in a chemistry lab in my phd for like
five years
of atmospheric chemistry obviously i
don't run atmospheric chemistry models
for my job
but i didn't think that was like a waste
of my time or something i couldn't
engage in
and i did these interdisciplinary papers
with scientists who
are working on models and i helped
explain you know what are the policy or
political implications of that
and so having this knowledge in a lot of
different areas is extremely powerful
for the climate and energy space
because it is technical it is
science-based
um there's so many disciplines that
weigh in on what we do
um and so that's been a really critical
thing in terms of my learning and i feel
that it is something that sets me apart
from many others and that i can
dialogue fairly fluently with very
technical people even though
i am a political scientist policy expert
whatever
so i would really encourage people to do
that to stretch outside of their comfort
zone take different classes
learn basic science and engineering
because it really is a great foundation
for the work work in interdisciplinary
spaces with folks who are open to it
and everybody i worked with throughout
the way was very applied and normative
even if they were asking
sort of very positivist questions and
doing very you know rigorous
work and that always creates a community
of solidarity where
all of us are mission focused even if we
come from different communities so so
that's really what i would say
um is probably my advice i would also
encourage people to join organizations
get involved in climate activism if
that's something that they feel strongly
about
you know it isn't something that i did a
lot because in the early years because i
as you can probably tell i'm a fairly
nerdy person i like studying and writing
and learning
and i i didn't feel as comfortable with
protesting or things like that
but other people might feel the opposite
and i think we've seen just how powerful
protesting is to the movement and
this is something that i'd of course do
more now and ayanna johnson who's one of
the
editors of this book she always says
that you know the climate movement needs
everything
and so whatever your talents are you
should bring that to the movement um
you know if you could if you write music
some people write songs about climate
change or
if you um you know uh like writing you
can write about things if you like
organizing you know you can lend those
resources to help organize
groups and get things done and so
whatever you like whatever is your
passion or skill
that is something that the climate
movement can use um and so i would just
encourage people to
uh bring their skills to the movement
well thanks so much for that and that's
really good advice for everybody here i
think to follow i'm especially thinking
about all the interdiscipline
opportunities you have and if you're an
undergraduate yield and a graduate
student yell just the sheer amount of
different classes that you can take
um so one last question from me which
i'm sure is sort of on everybody's minds
um
obviously you right now are deeply
engaged in your reports and your work on
the potential policies that the biden
administration can try to pursue
um through reconciliation i imagine also
maybe some things through unilateral
action at the epa or otherwise
so i'm curious um what do you think
the most what would make you optimistic
of something big happening
um in the next two years or what do you
think the most likely good thing to
happen in the next two years is
well i'm already very optimistic i think
the biden and
harris administration has staffed up
very aggressively on climate and energy
i know many of the people who are
holding key positions and they
are dogged advocates for the right side
of history so i feel very very strongly
that this is um
going to be a landmark administration on
climate and clean energy
and i think what i am looking forward to
is the
next bill the budget reconciliation bill
that starts
in a maybe a month or two um on
on the build back better climate and
clean energy agenda
um i think it's going to be absolutely
transformative to our society
and uh i think we're going to pass it
and that is not what i would have said
years ago you know that's where the
power of the youth climate movement
of so many people from you know governor
inslee running for president
also the impacts of climate change and
practice like heat waves and and fires
and
hurricanes like the ipcc 1.5 degree
report there's all these factors greta
tunberg right like
all these factors have just raised the
salience for politicians so much more of
our issue and we're no longer a tier 2
issue we're really a top flight issue
not just for the biden men but for many
senators and representatives so
i am extremely hopeful that the package
will include a clean electricity
standard
as well as other key investments on
buildings
transportation electricity making sure
we deal with ej
issues we are investing in the
transition into disadvantaged
communities that are
formal thoughts former fossil fuel
communities or former sites of polluting
infrastructure
um i just think that this is like this
is the actual marquee 2.0 without the
cap and trade bill without the cabin
trade part of it and
um yeah it's like the biggest
opportunity in more than a decade and
it's coming it's coming very fast
so i spent all day every day on that
pretty much um
and i feel really really hopeful and
excited that we have a chance
and the general timeline that people
talk about is like
maybe march or april until august or
september
is when this bill would be negotiated so
it's happening
i would encourage people to plug into
organizations as we get closer to bills
write to your
senator right to your representative
keep the pressure up because we've just
seen the power of people pressure
to get climate change at the top of the
agenda
that's great to know and that gives us
all uh something to look forward to
hopefully and certainly to keep close
tabs on
um and perhaps advocate for because
again i know how many of you care about
this that are in our audience
um so we're just about at time um so i'd
just like to say a couple of things
before we conclude um one is i know that
many folks in the chat a few of you
have asked whether the video of this
whole event will be available because i
think you want to go back
learn more because there's just so much
knowledge and information
um packed into leah's presentation for
us all to take away
so that video um will be made available
and it will be directly um
emailed out to those who have attended
today um to go back and look at
i would also encourage you all if you
are users on twitter
to follow professor stokes on twitter um
i think
i am probably one of many many political
scientists
who follow you um for many reasons but
as sort of the primary source of
our information and news about climate
policy and politics so
if you're looking for you know a great
source of information on all fronts on
these issues highly encourage you to do
that
um and more generally i would encourage
everybody to go get this book
it is fantastic um obviously if you care
about climate and energy policy um
you'll learn a lot from it
um if you're you know an american
politics graduate student or frankly
just anybody interested in politics and
a new take on some classic questions in
political science
you're also going to get that out of
this book um so go do that and read it
and finally just thank you so much
leah for being with us today amid your
very busy schedule
um of work towards a better outcome in
these areas we so appreciate it um
and i know that all our faculty students
and staff have learned a lot today so
thank you very much
thanks so much for having me great to be
here with all of you and hope everybody
hangs in there with the pandemic